[Music]
many people think that as you rise to
the ranks and become successful and you
start earning money as an
african-american that all of this
prejudice interaction goes away that it
doesn't exist but you can walk into a
building and a guard in the building
because of the way you look the way you
dress decides he or she is gonna put you
in your place they're gonna show you who
has the power here so when that happens
you have a whole different dynamic that
you have to deal with and I can tell you
from experience that when this happens
to you other white people around you
don't see it they just don't see it but
you can tell by the tone of voice the
way they delay dealing with you all of
these subtle things tell you what's
going on and then you have to find a way
if this is a place you come to
repeatedly to adjust but the major thing
I tell everyone is that you have to get
this out of your soul before you go home
because you can't take this type of
anger into your house because it's steep
it sits there it festers and that anger
becomes more undermining long term
because eventually you're gonna walk
into a building and somebody's gonna do
that to you and you're not going to be
able to handle it you're gonna lose your
temper today I feel that if you live in
a big urban area you can basically have
whatever identity you want because
people will at least not in general
attack you yell at you call you names
that does happen but you can go through
a whole day maybe a whole week without
that happening when I was growing up I
was lucky
if I could get through a day not being
reminded in a pejorative way that I was
black that I am black it was tough you
develop a series of walls when that
happens and you learn to sort of adjust
those walls some of them are more
flexible than others and some some are
pretty solid and you adjust those walls
depending upon how you think people are
perceiving you I can tell you that I can
walk down the street now sometimes in
New York especially in London and I
don't even think about the fact I'm
black
it just doesn't enter my mind I'm just
walking down the street and then at
other times I'll go into a building
having had a walk and the guard at that
building will put his body right in
front of me and it's an aggressive move
because he has decided just seeing me
walk into the building that something is
inappropriate or something he needs to
challenge about that I think that a lot
of people don't experience that in their
day-to-day life still I think it's
something that's unique to people of
color I think a lot of it you need to
male people of color and particularly
black men and the majority society
thinks you're being paranoid I'm gonna
tell you a story I was working for a big
corporation regularly coming to the
building every week there was a guard at
the building I had to sign in and
provide him with my details every week
no I am NOT a retiring flower I engage I
talk every time I came to that building
he would not look at me and then when I
walked away he would say put the badge
on your jacket
it wasn't a wreck
it was a command and I would put the
badge right in the middle and then
sometimes if I was wearing a really nice
suit I put her on my hand and hold my
hand up like that and walk forward one
day we had a little confrontation about
this I said listen
this is good that's getting me into the
building you see me every day he
pretended he didn't when I came back the
next time it had gone all the way up to
the people in the building the company I
was working for and they request that
that I change my ways and I said how
long have you known me
and they took answer that question
that's it have you had problems with me
coming in this building before they said
no but maybe something's changed about
you that was coded language
it wasn't the guard who was a problem it
was me with that I didn't say another
word I then changed the way I dress when
I came in and I made no eye contact with
him whatsoever
and eventually I decided to tell the
Human Resources people about the
situation nothing happened so the type
of freedom that people think exists
doesn't exist for everybody today so
whether you're a gay transgender no
whatever you're gonna run into some
problems some point so I think that
people think that these problems don't
occur they think that it's something
that you are being paranoid about but no
it happens subtly every day and you're
reminded that you are different so yes
some people can be more open and not
encountered that but some of the rest of
us we get these little reminders and
then you have to walk away from it and
hopefully as my parents said don't bring
it back into your own house
[Music]